[Music]
welcome back to another highly organized
episode of careful boys we have with us
davidso today and geo carefully mom and
joe and joe and lift god and anthony and
can we start off this episode real quick
new hair with the elementary rap from
lift god real quick my favorite oh my
god i cannot believe hey but it's a beat
for me though yo get that beat
[Music]
i put my black shoes on with an all
white shirt people look at me look i
look like they're forget them fools i
ain't no fool i ride on 24's on my way
to school no i ain't black but i ain't
white ass snow i get a lot of stuff like
i've lost a toe and now i got a lot of
friends but not a lot of money and i
don't like sugar but i like honey now
i'm in sixth grade i'm not that smart my
favorite kind of food is a cherry pop
tart no
so i'm not that tall so in that bathroom
i pee in the stall and i know how to
sing the abc and i'm lactose intolerant
so i don't eat cheese now imma end this
song right about now i don't wanna
answer i'm gonna end y'all with a bout
all right
now do it over in the
river
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] nuts tell the back
story can you sing uh mary had a little
lamb like that
yeah
it's crazy crazy huge right
hey there's a technique it's not the
same vibe i know we're not supposed to
use this word that was a little [ __ ]
hey man i tried my best dude
he tried his best yo i can't do that to
him hey nick your turn dude i'll teach
you let me i'll show you the technique
on how to do it
did you just survive throat cancer
that's the deepest i could go that
doesn't even sound like a screen val
kilmer over here dude all right that's
not even
a scream have you guys seen those
moments
yeah those mongolian throat singers
there's a [ __ ] oh yeah mongolian band
called the who it's [ __ ] all you mean
we're the arms wide open oh yeah
they're mongolian
how'd you get into that [ __ ] that's so
random what's random his the throat yeah
that's not random look at what he's
it really was tony hawk pro skater i
think it was like two or three because
on one of the one of the songs is iron
maiden a number of the beasts
so like we like that song a lot and then
we asked my dad like hey have you ever
heard of the song and he's like yeah why
he's like have i and we're like oh it's
cool and then he literally like went to
the garage and grabbed out all of his
records and had like slayer iron maiden
pantera all this because i've been
[Laughter]
i think the first van was a band called
job for a cowboy they were local to
arizona and we listened to them and it
was like that style of music and my
brother was getting a guitar so like we
were like oh this is sick how do you
learn how to sing like that that's crazy
so i watched a youtube video like a long
time ago because i used to scream wrong
so like i used to scream and i couldn't
even talk were you first doing it like
no
japanese porno yeah
and he goes it doesn't sound right dog
my dad's like hey what the [ __ ] y'all
watching down there i'm like oh my god
um no like i used to do i forget how i
did it but yeah i used to not be able to
like talk when i watched a youtube video
and it was like super simple and it like
made sense and it was like there was i
think it was like four steps so the
breathing the breathing is the first
part so it's like imagine you have a
window right here and you're trying to
fog it
so you use your dive almost like when
you're lifting right you squeeze at your
diaphragm or like right here right
it's like so then the second step was it
smells in here yeah
the second step is like if you're taking
a [ __ ] yeah and you're squeezing really
hard you go
i peed a little
now you do the breathing technique when
you do that noise
it's like you change it so then you can
try to the the smaller you make your
mouth
and then also like it depends on where
you place your tongue so like
it changes the tone and then the screen
one i'm about to do
my ass
no the high one is like you open up your
mouth wide and kind of have like your
tongue out so
[Applause]
so like when i just i just got back into
it so i haven't done this
that's not bad though honestly there's a
right way to do it that you're not
damaging yourself right i almost threw
up though and i peed a little so i'm
pretty sure i'm doing it wrong that's
when i first started i was doing that
too but like here we go
but it takes a little bit
there's like hardcore vocals with just
like literally shouting and [ __ ] but uh
yeah i don't feel like i did it that was
ricky martin my voice was like shot a
little bit like the bro science way was
like basically what you're doing is
you're cutting up your throat and then
it heals and it kind of builds scar
tissue that's very bro back when i was
like 16 17 when we were in a band like
they told you you need to do that yeah
but i would scream like i'd be able to
do set or we'd practice for like two
hours and i'd walk out my voice is
perfectly fine
yeah so you know how like in singing
people have like warm up and practicing
they'll be like
like that right yeah so is there some
kind of thing like that when you do it
the first lows that i did right here
that i could tell that they weren't
sounding good but right now when i was
showing you i was like all right
sounding better i just to warm up i just
practice songs
it's so different when he does it
oh god god damn it dude it's very
similar born a [ __ ] no that sounds
like an emergency okay my bad
is very similar very similar that's an
ambulance yeah that's great there's
people that sound like that though in
bands bro
that just screech at the highest picture
pterodactyl that's eagle [ __ ]
[ __ ] jurassic park cover man like
they're just screaming like the lincoln
park right summon your little powers
hey that'd be sick like right before a
heavy ass breakdown hell yeah dude hey
just let me come in real quick
but there's also pig squeals too and
it's like inhaling
what the [ __ ]
you're good at that one
yeah nice chorizo
but i just got back into it starting up
a band so hell yeah
hey how are you gonna ask us any one of
us you can ask anyone he asked me we all
played music you didn't tell me i
so we had our first practice on
wednesday so we haven't really like done
anything so we're still kind of like
testing it out yeah it was cool i
haven't been to a band practice since i
was like 17. how do you write music for
the [ __ ] because it's just it's so
scribble it like crazy
it's just cursive
[Applause]
you take a dead sea scroll and you stab
it
the only way isn't there a lot of
biblical [ __ ] in there sometimes it
depends on the type of band there's like
christian death corps there's a
christian death corps they write it on a
[ __ ] lamb
there's christian heavy banshee like pod
is a christian like pod is christian
yeah they're they're a christian band
and not creed
i don't know but kriegle's hard bro
everybody hates on creation i thought
creed was christian band they were
originally so when they when they went
commercial they stopped being a
christian you know who's also a [ __ ]
christian band that i didn't know no
gospel gangsters the killers oh really
yeah mr bright side
the best bright side of our god yes bro
listen to the lyrics tick tock toes see
i don't know any of this white people
music [ __ ] so who are they the killers
oh mr broy sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was pretty good thank you thank you
i just saw how your eyes get really
small
about that smile too i'm auditioning for
ching chong man
[Laughter]
imagine trying to get signed well you're
going to love us
tonight
which players do you guys have so far
like which instruments do you guys have
we have so i'm the vocalist he's trying
to get in your band
opening my homie alessandro he plays
guitar and then uh his friend that i
just met for the first time on wednesday
he's named ricky he does a drum so we
want we were like let's kind of like jam
a couple times to see how it feels is he
like a hot drummer because you always
got to be careful of hot drummers in
movies why because they always take all
the girls
is that true though drummers get the
most [ __ ]
they [ __ ] better they're hot really
so you find the drummer the most
attractive
yeah i don't know about that either but
anyways
[Laughter]
what stroke had a hell of [ __ ] hey
bart's a drummer aren't you
i don't know
i'll tell you this though girl drummers
are [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] yeah hey one of
my old bands in arizona we had a girl
drummer and she was a [ __ ] she was
fine was she on beat though oh she was
so good i remember we used to go record
with our other band it used to take like
three hours right especially for the
drums because our old drummers were
really good but they weren't like they
didn't want to play on tempos and [ __ ]
right they were really good but didn't
know how to play on tempo no like well
it's like my brother he never actually
he doesn't know chords or anything he
learned off of tabs but when you see him
play you're like oh my this kid's
[ __ ] amazing i could talk that metal
is [ __ ] crazy too but
she was so good i remember
she gave the guy like all the tempos
right she gave him like all right this
tempo at this section this section this
section she did her drums in one take
wow and we were like holy [ __ ] all right
this is nice but and metal drumming is
like you got the double [ __ ] going
the girl drummer got titties and they
and then her left hip hits the [ __ ]
stairs
[Laughter]
you guys are so stupid
that would be that would be so tight
oh yeah this is hot cause you don't have
a name yet right
we haven't officially like made it a
band yet but it's we had our first
session on wednesday and it went really
well so you made the name something that
you had to say it like
otherwise like you don't respond yeah
yeah the name is bad you guys are
missing a bass player huh yes i played
basically we had we were supposed to
have somebody still trying to edge
himself in hey you guys raise the bass
player huh i play
i can play upright bass the kettlebells
[Laughter]
30 minutes later hey you guys need like
a neutral you guys don't have a [ __ ]
keyboard
i don't even know how to play metal with
it we gotta do band auditions for alex
what yeah what is going to a medal wait
you guys don't have a choreographer uh
you guys don't have a tambourine
hey that just might be dope though dude
like you know when i when i think of
music like when [ __ ] like this happens
i'm like that'd be cool you don't have
aggressive tambourines
you don't have will ferrell cowbell yeah
yeah
that's metal tambourine right for like
death core like
really you could do it with one
guitarist one bassist a drummer and a
vocalist
back in the day we play we had two
guitarists that played on seven streams
so my brother so it's seven strings so
it was already heavy so like at that
point we didn't really care if we didn't
have a basis or not so we were just like
whatever but then at one point we had
three guitars with seven strings and we
were like when we got really good at
towards the end before we broke up like
our shows were really tight and [ __ ] so
we had three guitars our [ __ ] was just
heavy as [ __ ] and this was just for this
is for fun whatever you're doing now
well back in the yeah now it's just for
fun but back in the day we were like oh
we're going to be a [ __ ] it'd be
really dope if you guys got into
arguments but you guys screamed at each
other
you were okay
i'm gonna hook you up right now with a
new school
like that that's metal right there
that'd be sick right
right now
please
pick a really really weird name i love
those like have you ever seen that band
where the name is just three exclamation
marks what stuff like how do you even
have you heard of the have you heard of
the band just
i guess you say it like
that's like how you say it yeah it's
three exclamation points this is how
they're like very fast just point things
out
because that's that when you see it
spelled out i've seen them on like set
list and it's it's like chk chk chk how
about comic comic official thing is
we'll see i don't know i i me personally
i like like one word band names mom mom
rover give it up for mom
hey but see i think that would be dope
though like you hire me manager
she has a really big mom
rolodex of like music she knows like the
most countries
she's already she knows so much [ __ ]
music is unreal like across genres she
probably she's probably the biggest
music library i know no how come
i don't know no but like any any song
she hears she could like just oh that's
[ __ ] francis kuglimovskis
hey hey he go hard he go hard geo named
this song
50s 60s 20s
name this song i'm a wonderful singer
there's no words though you got this
okay
most of the people here will know the
song ready it goes
you killed my master
this is [ __ ] like she knows that [ __ ]
you're just giving too much love to her
dude
no they're playing in all the [ __ ]
martial arts movies like literally all
the martial arts movies
but you know like when you see people
they'll fake the [ __ ] like a song will
come on and like oh i love that [ __ ]
she'll say it and she'll know the
[ __ ] lyrics it's unreal no no no oh
come on
what song is this
[Laughter]
is that the actual song yeah i'm sorry
my friends on the spectrum
that's the
[Laughter]
that is the magic mountain song
did
[Laughter]
fair that's a google movie story it's
really hard you know [ __ ] like like
sammy davis junior's nephew song or
[ __ ] like all kinds of crazy [ __ ] wow
testers sing some [ __ ] wait did you do
your parents listen to a lot of music
too um so
no they don't but they all had so many
different genres of like so like my mom
liked the beatles a lot my dad liked a
lot of like soul mole top motown type
[ __ ] my brother liked 80s so like
morrissey the smiths also just
differentiated
yeah yeah
one last one last test to prove your
value a real sound though
finish the lyrics oh no
ooh baby do you know what that's worth
i don't know
[Applause]
helen is a place on earth
you have to sing the first part and then
i'll come in with that ooh
baby do you know what that's worth
oh
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah all right one more
baby time you know what that's worth
oh baby it's a place
that was good that was very good i said
the wrong words
you can't say happy to that voice you
can't try that kook
you [ __ ] fraud
oh